[Music]
on this tuesday night
the delta variant and children covid
compounds the back to school jitters
again not just me i'm worried about the
people
around me plus how politics affect
public health measures
there's a considerable degree of
divisiveness in our country
our interview with dr anthony fauci the
damning findings of a sexual misconduct
investigation
into new york's governor and his denials
that's not who i have ever been a
belarusian activist
exiled to ukraine and found dead the
suspicions he was murdered
plus a beloved basketball superstar
takes a pass
on toronto i'm so sad kyle lowry's
legacy
on and off the court
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
paula nasser good evening and thank you
for joining us
we begin with the big question on the
minds of canadian parents
and students with september fast
approaching and warnings of a potential
delta driven fourth wave
what will the coming school year look
like and what's being done to help
keep kids safe today the ontario
government unveiled its roadmap for
september
it plans to have all students back in
the classroom in person
unless they opt for remote learning
masks will be required indoors for
grades one and up
school boards are being told to be ready
to quickly shift to remote learning if
needed
though the province's top doctor says
he's confident closures
won't be necessary i really don't see
our schools closing
going into the fall and winter and
spring and
and i believe that's the same stance of
all of our medical officers of health we
will do our utmost to keep
schools open for all students and
families
one of the big variables is the delta
variant
now there's no evidence kids are more
risk but the problem is
there is no vaccine available for
children under 12
and that won't change by september in
tonight's top story abigail beeman
breaks down what we know about
delta and kids and what experts are
watching for
one child in the hospital from a
vaccine-preventable disease
is unacceptable daily protests in
edmonton and calgary since the alberta
government announced a big easing of the
rules
my greatest fear as a pediatrician and
as a mother
is that we're going to see children
hospitalized one of the big issues for
dr tacine latta
masks won't be mandatory in classrooms
this fall
i want to try my best to keep everyone
safe and i'll continue wearing my mask
ontario students must wear masks that
province released its back to school
road map tuesday
i think we have to normalize covet 19
for four schools
and have an approach that's prudent
that's cautious
but that realizes yeah we're going to
have a rise in cases the backdrop to
back to school planning and
worries rising cases of the delta
variant combined with children
under 12 who can't get vaccinated even
though in general severe outcomes for
children with covid19 are
very rare i can't say that the delta
variant will cause more severe disease
than other covalent infections in kids
dr jesse pappenberg says because
delta is more transmissible there will
be more cases but there is no data
showing it causes more severe outcomes
in children
will we see more hospitalizations
overall in the coming weeks and months
i have no doubt will that be reflected
in pediatrics
probably but right now i wouldn't say
that there's any
cause for alarm at this point children's
hospitals in calgary toronto ottawa and
montreal tell global news they have
not seen an increase in pediatric
admissions recently
but there are reminders cases do happen
some ontario campers had a very short
stay after an outbreak among at least
four campers and staff forced
muskoka woods to shut down for four
hours it was fun
and then we the counselor came in we got
the code alert
and then everyone just packed and
panicked kind of
as for when children under 12 could be
approved for a vaccine it certainly
won't be before
the school year clinical trials
including with canadian kids are in the
works with early results expected by the
fall
but full results and an application to
health canada are not expected until the
end of the year
abigail beeman global news ottawa
now to the u.s and florida specifically
where a major surge in
infections and low vaccination rates in
some areas
is having an alarming impact on children
according to the uscdc
the average number of children
hospitalized with covid19 in florida
has jumped 53 percent compared to the
previous week
on average 40 children were admitted per
day
in total last week the florida
department of health reported more than
10
700 new infections that's in children
under the age of 12.
new york city will soon require proof of
vaccination for indoor dining
gyms and performances if you're
vaccinated
all that's going to open up to you
you'll have the key you can open the
door
vaccinated americans will receive a
so-called key to nyc pass
it's going to provide proof of
vaccination for indoor activities
new york will be the first u.s city to
impose such restrictions
they will be enforced as of september
13th mayor bill de blasio says the move
is crucial to encourage
more vaccinations less than 50 percent
of all
eligible americans are fully vaccinated
once a leader the u.s
has now fallen behind canada and the eu
our jackson prosko recently sat down
with dr anthony fauci
the top infectious disease expert in the
u.s to talk about how
politics has impacted public health
measures
you know the vaccination rate in this
country has really struggled to get
above that 50 percent of eligible people
fully vaccinated there was so much hope
and optimism when these vaccines rolled
out at the start of the year
i'm wondering from where you sit would
you have predicted that it would be this
much of a struggle to get this much of
the american public vaccinated
no i i was hoping that we would get
an enthusiasm that would transcend
political ideology transcend
leaning towards one versus the other
depending
where you live and what the general
culture is in a particular area but
unfortunately
that's not the case where we've been
stuck now
is we have about a hundred million
people who are eligible to be vaccinated
who are not getting vaccinated
and we've really gone do anything we
possibly can to reach out to them
to get trusted messengers and even
in some respects to do some local
mandating which we're starting to see in
the country
you're going to see universities
colleges places of business
that are going to require vaccination
once that happens
you're going to start seeing more people
vaccinated
is there something different in the us
that's made it more difficult here
i think it's no surprise to anyone
certainly
across the border you recognize it
you're close to us
that there's a considerable degree of
divisiveness in our country
and unfortunately that's spilled over
into the public health
arena has the delta variant made the
politics even more difficult because
you've got people thinking now that
we're taking a step backwards we're
returning to
mass recommendations and mandates for
example all the issues we dealt with
months and months ago yeah it just
intensifies things because for the
people
who are saying that one thing makes a
difference it doesn't make a difference
it adds a lot more confusion to it we're
dealing with a different virus
now than we were several months ago
and that being the case the science
evolves
the evidence evolves and your approach
and your guidelines and your
recommendations need to evolve
you can watch jackson's full interview
with dr fauci on our website
globalnews.ca
slash global national canada is still
number one
in the world with more than 67 percent
of eligible people fully vaccinated
and though rates have plateaued we still
have millions of doses coming in
while countries like the philippines
kenya iran
and egypt have single-digit vaccination
rates
michael couture reports on canada's
unused doses and
are kovacs commitments
over the last week the number of doses
being administered daily in canada
has dropped by half and it's a problem
for two reasons
not only does it mean fewer people are
being protected against covet 19
but it means some doses could go to
waste no health care provider wants to
be in the precarious position of having
to
dispose of what is liquid gold in the
vaccines
when the vaccines arrive in canada
they're stored in freezers the provinces
place orders for how many doses they
believe
they'll need a month ahead of time and
those doses are shipped
to doctors offices pharmacies and
vaccination centers
but then the clock starts ticking once
they're thawed you really have about
28 days to use those vaccines
and you can't refreeze them or repackage
them and put them back in the box and
send them elsewhere they've got to be
they've got to be used dr bogash is part
of ontario's vaccine task force and he
points out
there has been far less wastage in the
covid19 vaccination campaign
compared to the seasonal flu those
soon-to-be expiring doses
can be moved across the province to
other regions
but it's just too complicated to donate
them to developing countries
if you look at the time to extract to do
the quality assurance to inspect every
single vial to make sure they're not
spoiled and then to ship it it's going
to take longer than a couple weeks
while some doses have already gone to
waste the government
is making sure the developing world gets
vaccines according to gavi
the vaccine alliance canada is fourth in
the world when it comes to donating
doses of covid19 vaccine to the rest of
the world
just ahead of japan that's in addition
to the hundreds of millions of dollars
pledged to purchase vaccines
for poorer countries a spokesperson from
the department of international
development acknowledged there is some
vaccine wastage in canada
but added it's less than one percent of
the nearly
60 million doses that have been
delivered to the provinces
farah michael couture in ottawa thank
you mike
u.s president joe biden is calling on
new york governor andrew cuomo
to resign a bombshell report from the
state's attorney general found cuomo
sexually harassed at least 11 women and
his office is accused of creating a
toxic work environment that prevented
women from coming forward
and even retaliated against one accuser
who went public
and we want to warn you some of the
details here are disturbing
this investigation has revealed conduct
that corrodes
the very fabric and character of our
state government
attorney general leticia james says
cuomo in his office violated state and
federal laws
the democratic governor's accusers
include nine current and former
employees
one was a state trooper and a member of
a security detail
the independent investigation
corroborated the accusations
by conducting nearly 180 interviews
and examining more than 74 thousand
pieces of evidence
including emails text messages audio
files and photos
cuomo who has faced calls to resign for
months denied the allegations
in a pre-recorded video address
i never touched anyone inappropriately
or made inappropriate sexual advances
the attorney general says the
investigation was a civil matter and any
criminal charges
will be up to law enforcement in
afghanistan tonight
a bomb went off near what's known as the
green zone in the capital city of kabul
it's another sign of volatility as
afghan forces combat a taliban
resurgence
[Applause]
the car bomb was detonated not far from
the home of the country's defense
minister
a short time later another blast and
gunfire in the same area
there has been no claim of
responsibility it happened as the
government urged civilians in the
capital of hellman province to evacuate
where security forces struggle to fend
off the taliban
the militant group is fighting to seize
more territory throughout afghanistan
ahead of the withdrawal of u.s and nato
troops after nearly 20 years
in the country and as the taliban gains
ground the canadian government
is facing pressure to act faster to
resettle afghans
whose lives are at risk because their
past work
helping canadian forces the threat is
real
and it requires immediate action
advocates took
their message to parliament hill they
want the federal government to expedite
the application process
for former interpreters and support
staff and family members
there are fears the taliban will
retaliate or murder those who were seen
as cooperating with foreign forces
last week the u.s brought in 200 former
interpreters and family members
and on monday it expanded the
eligibility for refugee status
in montreal three men are dead and two
others injured after a brazen shooting
that's believed to be gang related
police say dozens of shots were fired
toward an apartment building around 7
monday night
all the victims are known to police
officers say the violence is
unprecedented in montreal police have
asked quebec's national police force for
specialized support to prevent potential
retaliation
a prominent activist from belarus is
found dead in ukraine
coming up the suspicions and the fears
he was murdered
an exiled belarusian activist has been
found dead in the ukrainian capital
vitaly shisho was discovered hanged in a
park
the main opposition leader of belarus
says she too
could disappear at any moment redmond
shannon reports on the growing fears of
being targeted
outside the country
a friend and colleague of vital shicho
describes the jogging route the
activists took
monday the body of the belarusian was
later found
hanging from a nearby tree
he called me last week and said he had a
bad feeling says the friend
and that if anything happened i should
look after his girlfriend
kiev police say they are investigating
whether it was suicide or
murder shisho was the head of a group
that helps belarusians in exile
if it was a targeted murder it sends a
chilling message
to those who have fled to ukraine
like the husband of belarusian sprinter
christina timonovskiya
they are both desperate to get to poland
after she criticized her olympic coach
in tokyo
a sporting spat that thrust her into the
opposition movement
and the international spotlight the
leader of the opposition movement to
atlanta tiganovskiya has been meeting
western leaders in recent months
asking them to put more pressure on the
regime of president alexander lukashenka
her latest stop here in downing street
we are committed to supporting the human
rights and
civil society in belarus after her
meeting with prime minister boris
johnson tiganovskiya reflected a growing
fear that belarusians outside the
country
are feeling unsafe i can i can disappear
at any moment i understand this
but uh i should do what i'm doing i
can't stop because i'm
uh uh you know i i i feel response
this responsibility for future of my
country a fear shared by some
belarusians in canada
i worry about a lot of my colleagues
even here in canada
two of my colleagues who are activists
and work with me
they've been on belarusian propaganda tv
with some threats that they will be
investigated and exposed
activists like elena lia von chancas say
the repression in belarus continues
and is getting worse ahead of the one
year anniversary of the disputed
election
next week redmond shannon global news
london
ahead the olympic gymnasts back on the
beam overcoming
mental and physical adversity
two big comebacks were front and center
at the olympics today
american gymnast simone biles returned
for the highly anticipated balance beam
final
and canada's ellie black also re-entered
competition
crystal commansing has the results and
details about a record day
on the track simone biles put herself
and her health first returning to
competition on the final day
she showed her strength she altered her
routine but still
earned a bronze her seventh olympic
medal in her accomplished career
i'm pretty happy i wasn't expecting to
meddle i just came out here
and just tried to do a good beam set the
games have been
tough on the world renowned gymnast she
qualified for
five events and was heavily favored to
win multiple
golds but the 24 year old was struggling
with her mental health and pulled out of
all but this event
canada's ellie black supported her
fellow gymnasts calling her courageous
black also just returned to competition
after
injuring her left ankle in tokyo black
is the top
canadian female gymnast and she was
determined to have a strong
finish her performance impressed she
scored a personal
best it left her briefly in third place
but
she was edged off the podium by 16 year
old
guan cheng cheng who captured gold
afterwards black
said that it's been tough but she's
proud of her performance
while the nation's medal count didn't
move records
did fall on the track andre degrasse set
a new canadian record in the 200-meter
sprint semi-finals
finishing in just 19.73 seconds
fellow canadian aaron brown finished his
heat just a little slower
at 19.99 in his heat
three sprinters appeared to cross the
finish line at the exact
moment a review determined brown
finished first
that means in the field of nine
sprinters there will be two canadians in
the final
doubling the country's odds of capturing
a medal
wednesday degrasse did win silver
in this event back in rio crystal
gamansen global news
london kyle lowry says goodbye to the
raptors
up next the legacy he's left in toronto
it's a bittersweet end of an era for
canadian basketball
yesterday nba player kyle lowry made it
official
he's saying goodbye to the toronto
raptors to play for the miami heat
as shawn o'shea explains he leaves
behind legions of fans forever grateful
even as they see him go in the adults of
toronto sports
kyle lowry's name looms much taller than
the guard six foot frame
he's the face of the franchise for the
toronto raptors but a basketball player
who had a shaky start here nine years
ago
guy with a okay iffy reputation and as a
bit of a hot head and
a guy who butts head with coaches to
this beloved beloved teammate
lowry made his mark with the team and
the fans during the raptors 2019 playoff
run
ending with a first ever championship
off the court lowry was frequently just
as entertaining
we have a special guest here by taking a
press conference phone call from his
friend the rapper drake
i'm his translator you know you're not
or when he received an honorary
doctorate from acadia university this
spring
i will not respond to anything other
than dr lowry
what kind of doctor you're going to be
dr letters a doctor of what
doctor of greatness at the same time
larry connected with people through his
charitable foundation
and his motivating words how will you
pay it forward
what will be your impact on your
community in lowry square in east
toronto a street sharing the superstar's
name
we're very proud as a torontonian a
young family moved into their house
just a couple of days ago just as larry
moves out of the city
i know it's hard to say goodbye to him
but we
could still see him like in other court
it hurts
but uh he he has to be one of the
greatest raptors of all time
it's sad he's the you know first of all
the greatest raptor of all time
larry's moving to the miami heat for a
reported 90 million dollar
three-year contract and a shot at
another championship ring
it's gonna be a little weird to watch a
raptor team without him
the end of an era but in a city that was
starved for a sports championship
lowry's legacy as the driving force
behind it is sealed
shadow shea global news toronto and that
is global national for this tuesday i'm
faran asser thank you so much for
spending part of your evening with us
tonight's your canada is the terry fox
monument in thunder bay ontario
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other
you